council hawkway i've just gone through
all the
protocols for the meeting are you
comfortable with all those do i need to
repeat them for you
yeah sorry miss them so um don't you
want to do that again for me please
okay um
so it's just to remind you to turn your
mobile off or to
silent set your microphone to mute
during the meeting
if you are wanting to speak please click
your icon
and wait to be to be called remembering
to unmute your
microphone when we come to voting we'll
do that in line with the
procedure in the constitution i'll ask
about a recorded vote
first if we reach the appropriate number
we'll take the recorded vote
otherwise the voting won't be done uh by
a click of hands
um as i instruct you um and remember
that we are going to be
strip or we are i think just been
streamed on the
on the youtube channel so um please be
aware of that so i think we're actually
ready to start okay
right good evening members and welcome
to the
development committee 22nd of april 2021
as uh we're informed this is the last
formal council meeting of the municipal
yeah
and welcome to anyone that is watching
us on the council's
youtube streaming um
apologies for absence apologies have
been received so far
from councillor mr shaw councillor mrs
shaw
councillor weston and councillor
iano in terms of substitutes
for um substitute members
we've got councillor gooding for
councillor mr shaw
councillor belton for councillor mrs
shaw councillor stepped over councillor
mrs
weston and i
believe that is it and then we have
non-members attending
councillor sparing i think i've covered
every one item four
minutes of the meeting hound on the 25th
of march
2021 will you be happy and do of course
for those to be accepted
as a true and accurate record of that
meeting please
indicate by the clicked hand by the
raise icon
if you've got any issues uh if you've
got any issues i i'll assume
acceptance and unless you click
so council america i'm still seeing your
no your hands gone down okay we'll
accept those
those minutes then right uh item five
declarations of interest
i've got um i've i've got an item to
read out here in connection with
um item six on the committee
on on the on the agenda um i should just
make it
clear in case anyone is still looking at
an old copy of the
agenda um the original item
six um cherry orchard brick works
that item has deferred been deferred and
we'll come back to the
committee in due course so
with regards to the land to the west of
the car park
cherry orchard jubilee country park
that's application twenty slash
zero one one two eight dash out this
application is made on the council's
land
by a third party this is illegal
this is legally acceptable in planning
terms
however if granted the council will
benefit from the application
there would be an other pecuniary
interest for members of the committee to
declare
with that in mind we still need to
consider the business before
us as we are the local planning
authority
accordingly pursuant to section 33 of
the localism act
2011 and the authority delegated to the
monitoring officer
by the council under minute 86-12
she has granted a dispensation to all
members
of the development committee and their
substitutes
for the application twenty slash zero
one one two eight
slash out on the basis that without the
dispensation the number of persons
prohibited
by section 31 brackets four from
participating in any particular business
would be so great a proportion of the
body transacting the business
as to impede the transaction of the
business this dispensation is for a
period of one year
i'll also um mention that you're
respectfully reminded that as members of
the development committee you
you are aware that when making a
decision on a planning application you
must take a proactive role
and take account only into planning
uh considerate material planning
considerations
also on that particular application
a number of members may well be a a
acquaintance of the planning agent and
if so you should declare
a non-pecuniary interest
so with that in mind it's taken as read
that we have now all got a dispensation
as members for the cherry orchard
can i ask for declarations
to be made i'll just start with myself
in that i have a non-pecuniary
interest by virtue of my acquaintance
with the planning agent for the cherry
orchard application
councillor steptoe thank you chairman
uh first of all i i have as war
counsellor and county councillor for the
same area
non-pecuniary interest as uh as you've
already stated with regards to the
uh agent um i know is known to me
and also the applicant themselves
being non-pecuniary interests correct
thank you
councillor williams thank you chairman
likewise i have a non-pecuniary interest
in by virtue of the fact that i am a
award member parish council chairman
of that area um and the applicant and
the applicant's agent is known to me
so that's a non-binary thank you thank
you councillor gooding
uh for me chairman it's a
non-procurementary
interest in the uh knowing the planning
agent
thank you thank you councillor merrick
thank you chairman um in relation to
item seven i ha i declare a
non-pecuniary interest
by virtue of being acquainted with the
uh
agent and in relation to item nine
uh i am uh uh this
property is within the uh in my ward
and i have had some limited discussions
uh concerning this development but
only in relation to access so it does
not affect
this particular application thank you
councillor fd
thank you chairman nonpakuni interest
with the uh applicant's agent
thank you councillor belton
thank you nonparty in the virtue of
knowing the
agent thank you thank you
um it's quite a complicated list can i
just check that
uh mr irwin's content with everything
that
has got on the details yes chair thank
you thank you very much
so that takes as we mentioned our item
six this item has been deferred for
a future meeting of the committee
so we are now on to item seven which is
land to the west of
um cherry orchard jubilee country park
um i've forgotten who's taking this one
is it mr strengths
thank you
thank you chairman um this application
is on a site on part of the cherry uh
orchard country park west of
the existing car park and access if you
can
cursor the uh new access off the
roundabout please katie and show the
location of the
the car park um that's the roundabout so
we go that's fine thank you and then
obviously our site has
edged um which shows us broadly h-shaped
uh structure which i'll explain this
application is in outline form with all
matters reserved that means that
the usual matters we sometimes pick up
about access perhaps or
citing um they're not for consideration
this night it's just the principle
of the development on on the site before
you
the applicant has put forward a concept
of what such a visitor center might
include but these details are indicative
only
and that just helped uh for an
understanding of of the application and
to help members
if outline planning permission were
granted it would obviously be necessary
for a detailed reserve matters
application to come back before you at
some stage
clearly setting out the favored design
and its impact for consideration
the scheme suggested would include a
reception area an office base for
management of the sites
educational space to one wing if we can
jump to the floor plans briefly
please katie a display in retail space
i don't know if we'd be able to
centralize that i'm probably being
faster and unkind to my help but um
you'll see it's probably a
uh h-shape plan chairman to the right of
your screen i appreciate that the
notation is upside down there's no need
to rotate it katie
but you'll see the area that's been
suggested as would be
as of an educational space display areas
and the opportunity to have groups on
site and perhaps look at the ecology
things like this the central area the
cross
wing to the h would be a broad reception
area
and the sort of box behind that would be
office for administration
to the left of the uh reception that's
right there'll be public toilets so
there's a disabled toilet there a male
and female
and then on the far wing you'll see that
there's a
facility for cafeteria with the kitchen
behind now this is not
necessarily for decision tonight to
agree that layout particularly it's just
an idea
of what the applicant said a typical
visitor center may well look like
for members tonight it's agreeing an
outline permission
if that's your your gift to
um then come back in detail
at a later stage the applicant has also
given us a 3d visual which we just have
a brief look at
and you'll see from the report that this
would be suggested to be timber designed
and timber framed
and you'll note on the roof there the
sedum
uh planting eco-friendly roof and
this suggestion it doesn't necessarily
mean that if it proved this is what it
would look like
but this is particularly low rise and
low cli which you know
something like this would have a minimal
impact
on the green belt if we can go back to
the
location plan please members will
understand that the site is
in the green belt it's also within the
upper roche valley designation in the
council's adopted
local plan for landscape purposes whilst
most buildings would be inappropriate in
the green belt national policy does
allow for appropriate facilities
for outdoor recreation and where the
harm
to greenbelt is outweighed by the public
benefit
and the openness of the air is
essentially preserved so this
application that
would be a relatively small building in
the context of the size of the
country park itself it's only a small
part of the
country park which is proposed to relate
to this application
the um benefits obviously with
refreshments and comfort facilities
they would outweigh in officers view the
harm to the green belt
the access and car parking area is
already established as the size
proposed is indicative only we would not
be able to ascertain at this outline
stage whether additional
car parking is required but if if the
application is approved and pursued to
detailed reserve matters at some stage
that would be an opportunity to revisit
once we understand the full floor space
um the proposal would accord with policy
clt 5 of the council's adopted course
strategy for the opportunity for public
conveniences
in public open spaces and with the
display area inside the building
some possibility for public heart the
preliminary ecological appraisal finds
no conflict with a proposed site in
likely to harm any protected species and
members will have seen that the
council's arboriculturalist sees no
issue with any trees on this
part of the site where the proposal is
proposed similarly
archaeological features are unlikely to
be impacted i believe because
the site was at one time a mineral
extraction
the capacity of the local sewage
treatment plant
would be able to take the flows of
rising um
on the agenda members will have seen
that a formal response of no objection
in reply to the notification has been
received from the council's assistant
director for assets
and commercial the recommendation is
therefore that the application be
approved subject to the conditions set
out in the report
thank you um mr strange just mentioned
the
the addendum there it literally just
does have one line on it
the response from as mentioned response
from the
district council's assistant director
assets and commercial
it simply says the council has no
observations
or comments to make at this time that is
the entire content of the addendum in
case anyone
hasn't seen it um i wonder if you would
mind stop
sharing your screen now and i can i can
see that can i just ask if our
non-member wishes to visiting member
neat wants to say anything at this point
okay right um councillor steptoe
as representing ward councillor please
thank you chairman um yes this is quite
a
an unusual application uh we do
occasionally have applications where
uh it's on somebody else's property by a
third party
uh but the first time i can recall where
it is on
our own property and uh
to be honest with you one wonders why
um and i think that's something that uh
a lot of us will be wondering uh
with the um the application okay okay
just
just for absolute clarity it's a point
you've made
but it's not a planning consideration in
any person tonight
i accept that kevin i do accept that
with regards to the application itself
um if this is not not delivered
and what i don't quite understand from a
planning point of view
is if the application is granted but the
um applicant does not deliver
does the app the planning permission
transfer back to the council as
landowner
well at this point
what we're determining is the principle
of development on that side
the the actual building itself would
need to return to us
for a further planning application so i
i think
question although i'll just ask officers
to answer it
it's not again part of our decision so
can i just ask
for uh mr strange if you could just
answer that question
yes yes chairman the planning permission
essentially runs with the land
so so effectively the applicant becomes
particularly involved if the application
was subject to a legal agreement and
they were
therefore hold obligations to the
consent but without perhaps being in
control of the land
but in this case um there is no
recommend there's no
uh legal agreement recommended to you so
effectively
uh the council's site would be given the
benefit of a
planning permission but it runs with the
land and it would be timed so
so the outline would last for three
years and if no further
submission was made for the necessary
reserve matters then the permission
would lapse
thank you thank you chairman there was
one other question i wanted to ask
okay when you look at the outline of the
area that uh we're talking about it is
right adjacent
to an area of the cherry orchard park
which is fenced off and is
non-intervention there's no intervention
uh
i do have a concern that it is that
close to that
as to what effect that that may have on
that particular
aspect of the park itself um i would
have preferred to see
the area just cutting short of that
non-intervention area so there's no
disturbance
to the the wildlife that is uh uh
taken up um within that non-intervention
area
okay thank you uh i'll just get a couple
of other moments in a moment just for my
myself and to help um
the discussion um lately the discussion
um
this is in in green bound and i i feel
this particular proposed allocation of
land
is appropriate i think in terms of
uh additional things that we might like
to say perhaps by means of informative
in that the use of the the land by any
building should have a standard that
is at least meets the the safe by design
standard
mr strang's use the terms low rise and
low key
and i very much endorse those that that
terminology
for any formal design when it comes to
us
and then when any any further design
comes to us the capacity of that
building
should have a matched capacity
in the car in the adjacent car parking
and consideration should also be given
to coach access to the site because a
visitor center
might attract that with obviously um
awareness of other parties that might
like to bring larger vehicles onto the
site
in an unauthorized manner thank you
councillor eves thank you chair
um i like uh
councillor steptoe have severe
reservations about this and i understand
what you're going to say there chairman
but i need to put it on record that i
have reservations now the one thing that
i have
which is a concern about the actual
application is the position
the application is for it to be in a
particular position
in the park the applicant has had no
conversation with anyone as far as i'm
aware at the council
no interaction with anyone who has
connections with friends of cherry
orchard park
and so has no understanding of the
way the conversations have gone with
regards
to the use future use of the actual park
so my concern is that if we
actually agree that this is okay in the
position that is in
it is actually in the wrong position
this particular field that is in the
middle of
is the only place in the cherry orchard
park
uh areas various areas there are
where an event could be held to put
a
structure of this size right in the
middle of that park
could limit the kind of activities that
we could do
down there it does strike me
as though the applicant has
for whatever reason done this um
but has had no idea of the conversations
that have gone on and quite frankly
by bringing it to us now has wasted the
council's time
because we're going to have to go
through this exercise again once the
council
have decided what they want so at the
moment i cannot support this
this proposal because i believe the the
actual application is in completely the
wrong position in the park
thank you chair thank you uh councillor
stanley
thank you chairman um this has already
been indicated
and i've seen the site however
um there is
there is no other information given to
us
for the park itself and
what we aim to do with it and
to put this structure in without any
other information coming to us on
what is happening in the whole of the
area
i don't think that this is uh very
helpful to us and
i would like to know a lot more about
the area and what is happening rather
than
construct something before we actually
have the full
details of the whole site um
i don't know if that's possible or or
what's going on because
i don't feel that this the structure
we don't even know what the structure is
apart from being low level
and and uh in a conservation here so
you're quite you're quite right council
stanley we don't know what the structure
is
it's the principle of a structure
and i can't i can't agree with just
principles i'm sorry thank you um
councillor
williams i should have brought you in a
bit sooner as uh
as your ward covers this area so if
you'd like to go next please
thank you very much chairman um i i i
would fully support this
it's something that would benefit the
community as a whole i
see no doubt that it would will improve
the park
and i think the benefits would certainly
outweigh any detrimental facts from this
um and i i appreciate this is purely in
principle at the moment
i just wonder if i could ask mr strength
looking at the plan that we saw of the
of the area i believe that that car park
was prior to the enlargement can you
confirm if that's the case or not
so this would probably put it into a
little bit more scale if it's i'm sure
that's the smaller
i can't help you with that chairman um
i'm not i can recall the enlargement as
it is
if we were there on the ground but i i
suspect the members are right
it may be a smaller plan but i i don't
know either way i apologize for that can
we just ask
uh mr horton if he can offer some
information there
it's like could you bring the plan back
up on the screen for a second i'll be
able to recollect
quite quickly i'm printed into my mind
yeah outline of that card
if it helps katie we're looking for the
location plan
sorry chairman speaking out there it's
all right
it's an important question
there we go mr hot and then
that's the uh the original car park
because i mean so the the car park now
um runs almost the entire length of that
what what almost up to the start of the
red
um if you can imagine that red pathway
so it's a bit hard to say yes so there
so almost north to the existing car park
so that all that area there
is now car park okay so thank you very
much gives you a better idea of scale
thank you okay thank you councillor
hookway
please
thank you chairman um could i ask mr
strength um
whether um it was not possible
or was there some kind of constraints on
having
um the proposed building
uh much closer to the car park itself
and is there a particular reason for
um limiting the the area
in regard to the red line um if it was a
broader area it might give an
opportunity to
um have uh different ideas as to
the location of the proposed building
i'll take councillor gooding next in
case she's got any questions
that we can lump together counselor
gooding please
so if this is in principle i'm i'm now
wondering
in principle how much car parking space
we would need to accommodate this area
and where we would also in principle
place that
yeah uh mr strength do you want to come
back and
answer councillor hawkworth's question
thank you chairman i don't know if kate
is able to show the location plan again
just to our intake members but
the questions for you tonight is the
suitability of the area edged red
the uh i was rather hoping for the
uh location plan um
thank you you're being asked
for the agreement in principle of a
visitor center on
that area edge red we know the country
park is a much larger place
but the scope of your permission if you
like if you grant it is limited
to that area read expressed by the
applicant
now if members find
that they're unhappy with that
particular location something
there on that part of of the park then
they should be considering the
unacceptability of it if they if they
say well it should be i don't know
500 yards to the north or something like
that it wouldn't be within the area red
red it'd be on the country park but it
wouldn't be within the area's red that
is
that is an issue for members now on the
question of car parking
uses are normally um established
with a floor space that then translates
to a car parking
quantum so so many square meters of of
say
um restaurant cafeteria area
that would equate to i think one car
parking space every five square meters
something like that
okay now because this is uh
all matters reserved and whilst we have
a building to help us
in our minds that's what it might
something that it might look like
we couldn't rely on this particular
floor space because everything about the
design and the detail is reserved for
another day should you agree the
principle
so so we can't ascertain
if we were to say to you that building
requires x number of car parking spaces
that would be wrong because we'll have
done a calculation on a building that is
only a suggestion this is what i'm
thinking of
it's not we're not being asked to agree
a floor space quantum
and therefore know that the amount of
car parking we would require
now some schemes when you look at them
and we consult our colleagues at county
on highways
they might say that the existing car
park enlarged would be able to
accommodate
the demand in addition for this so it
wouldn't always be the case that we
might
settle on extra car parking being
required
but i take the point mentioned that you
know if the education facility that's
being suggested
might require then school groups etc
with uh
coaches and larger vehicles and things
like that that
of necessity would have to be dealt with
at a reserve matters stage
quite often developers say for flattened
schemes and buildings we're more used to
they ask for the sighting to be agreed
and that then naturally dictates the
floor space which then talks us into
car parking but this is expressly just
how about a visitor center on the area
edge red
what do you think about that all the
details we've seen it's always a danger
when we start getting
floor spaces that are indicative and the
appearance of buildings that are
indicative
whilst they help if we start deciding
whether that particular building
has adequate car parking it would be
wrong on this occasion because we're not
being asked
to agree that design until a further
reserve matters stage should that happen
i hope i've made that clear chairman
thank you
i i'm going to move the recommendation
and 11 points that are in the report
plus the informative about informatives
regarding safe by design low rise low
key
and as mr strength has just mentioned
car park matching
um capacity matching and consideration
for coaching
for coaches is there anyone that would
care to second me on that
answer lefty thank you so members the
um i think everyone has been able to
follow the points no one has had
intermittent connection
right okay so the recommendation
is for approval with the 11 points
as listed in the report plus the
informatives
as mentioned can i ask
if anyone would like a recorded vote
please raise your hand
that is the case
three three i believe the threshold is
reached
so i'm going to ask sonia to take us
through
a recorded vote please if that's all
right it is you going to do it sonia
no problem um counselor mrs butcher
would you like to vote for against or
abstain please
yes thank you i will be voting for
counselor mrs belton
four please
cancel fd
again totally the wrong position thank
you
councillors is gooding
thank you councillor hookway
i'm against the location but for the
principal
can i just ask for absolute clarity
there the motion
i'm against the motion as as he's
presented thank you
merrick paul
statue four
councillor williams thank you for
chairman that's that's eight four
and three against thank you members
that item is approved thank you
we next move on to item number eight
land to the north of london road and
west of roar of industrial estate
rorith lane rayleigh thank you chairman
i'm just going to share my screen
chairman this application seeks reserve
matters consent relating to scale
layout appearance landscaping and access
in relation to part of the strategic
landscaping
at the woolsey park development site the
location plan on screen
and edged red is the whole of the
woolsey park site which outlined
planning permission for largely
residential development of up to 500
homes was approved in 2016.
the approved parameter plan relating to
the outline
consent sorry
hopefully that would disappear
okay the approved parameter plan
relating to the outline consent is is
now on the screen
this plan identifies areas of the site
for residential development and
identifies an area of
strategic open space to the western
boundary
indicated just by my cursor here
this extends from roarth lane to the
north to london road to the south
specific details relating to the
northernmost section
of this western area so the plan on
screen has rora's
lane indicated by my cursor here towards
the top of the screen
so specific details relating to this
northern section have already been
granted reserve matters consent in 2017
the approved details are shown on the
screen and include areas
um for tree planting as well as
different areas for um different grass
mix planting
throughout the area um some two meter
wide hard surface paths were approved
providing pedestrian-only access routes
through the space
as well as additional paths that weren't
hard surface but were
formed of moan grass
the aerial image of the site as a whole
is now on the screen
and whilst a little out of date because
actually we've got far more development
now
um so far more construction having taken
place in this phase one where i'm
indicated by my cursor here
to towards the north so it's a bit out
today but you can still see
acro down the western side this is where
this strategic open space
is going to be developed
just zoom out a little bit
so the application now before members
tonight it's approval of the details of
the southernmost section
of open space towards the western
boundary this area would link
in this point here indicated by my
cursor
to the already approved section um to
the north
the feature the features and character
of the open space proposed
um in the southern section would mimic
those already agreed to the north
the space would feature a mix of
different grassed areas including areas
of moon lawn
so if i just um zoom in a bit
hopefully you can see the different
shades of green so
this lightest area of green indicated by
my cursor here and here
i'm just north of this path would be
closely known lawn with wildflower plugs
planted within
um and significant tree planting is also
proposed around this area
meadow grass so areas which where the
grass would be um
allowed to grow longer as shown in the
darker green and provide a different
character
to parts of the site other different
grass seed mixes would feature in other
areas
to add variety and interest to the
planting again a different planting mix
is proposed um around the attenuation
basins
um they're shown in the in the blue
color on the plan on screen
and the species here would be suitable
to the wetland environment
two meter wide self-binding gravel paths
are proposed similar to those ones to
the north and they're indicated in the
beige color you can just see
um winding through um this section east
west
indicated by my cursor and then going um
southwards joining
to the northern section here
again as was agreed in relation to the
northern section
um and indicated on the plan on screen
by the blue
hopefully you can see these blue dashed
lines around the
southern section of this attenuation
basin and then through
um this part here would be moan
footpaths that would weave through them
the grass three dog waste bins and two
benches are also proposed
so the dog waist bins are indicated by
the purple dots
maybe you can see me indicating with the
cursor on the screen approximately
center of the screen there
and then we've got two benches proposed
one just north of this attenuation basin
here and then one
um just towards the northern boundary
here
a post and wire fence 1.2 meters in
height is proposed along the western
boundary so this is along
this line here hopefully you can see
that by my cursor
um and then if i just scroll down again
to the bottom the only other boundary
fencing treatment that
is proposed on this plan is towards the
southern boundary
um with london road and this again would
be 1.2 meters in height
but would be a timber post and rail
fence and it would go
along the sort of southern boundary and
it's indicated by a blue line with blue
crosses
and it would extend just um up
part of the vehicle access off london
road
this would have a kissing gate and
that's shown
indicated in this insert um indicated by
my cursor here
to provide access and through for
pedestrians
and from london road the existing there
was an existing bridge
over the roareth brook just in this
position
hopefully you can see that by my cursor
on screen here
and this will be provided with a railing
so that's indicated
i could zoom in just slightly more it's
indicated by this um black
dashed line here specific details of the
species of tree and other planting will
be required to be provided in relation
to the landscaping planning condition
which was imposed on the outline
planning consent and those details will
be
submitted prior to any planting or works
in relation to the landscaping
taking place the proposed landscaping of
the southern section of the open space
follows that agreed in relation to the
remainder of the space to the north
and the recommendation therefore is one
of approval as set out in the officer
report
thank you
uh just ask our visiting member do you
wish to say anything no thank you
right uh members i just not seeing any
hands indicating at this moment in time
i think uh for me the key thing was
that uh as katie
explained that there was continuity in
style
mimicking what has already been approved
in the top part of the site i'm
councillor stanley you are the
award member and you've indicated should
you'd like to speak please
thank you chairman um could i ask katie
the kissing gate is this one that
the disabled could use uh if they're in
a
disabled mobile uh vehicle
as i know from uh looking at
mobility throughout uh uh
pastures or or walkways across
fields and what have you it is now not
exactly quite a kissing gate
it's more of a gate that they can
actually open from their mobile
unit so can you
elaborate on that and also the um
i know it sounds really terrible but do
you think we could have more
uh dog bins if you like closer to
the ponds area uh where people sit and
that sort of thing what not right on top
but
just away from there because they seem
to be that far apart it doesn't seem to
be
and we know for a fact that um with
with the swain park they are quite used
and overloaded at times
and and marcus holton will actually
vouch for that because
he's often cleaning them out um
we might laugh about it but it's a fact
uh people do take their dogs and we need
we need to make sure that the area is
he's almost
pristine if you like um could you
could you elaborate on those please if i
if i just take
um the other members and we'll group the
questions council steptoe
thank you chairman um two questions i'm
not sure if one will be relevant
um the first question is that you
mentioned there about railings where it
goes over the stream
will there be railings around the uh
attenuation
areas uh because they could be deep
water and will necessarily
lifeguard equipment be supplied as part
of that
um on the subject of the dog bins will
that
the
the maintenance of the bulking should we
say will that be part of the
um service charge that the residents
will be paying
or will with the that that fall over to
the
council to deal with chancellor eves
just one question uh when we're looking
at the southern part of the entrance
where you've got the kissing gate uh
note that the path there is an informal
path
as we're looking at that as a definite
entrance
into the greenfield area i'm wondering
if it's actually relevant to have it as
an
informal uh path because during the
winter periods that's going to become
extremely muddy
okay right that's all in the question so
if you'd like to sum things up and then
we'll
determine this one please okay thank you
um i'll just share my screen again
um so maybe let's take those
in in order
so in relation to the kissing gate
i just zoom into this bottom
so in this insert um the sort of
obviously we haven't got an elevation
plan showing what the fencing
would look like but this isn't sort of a
planned view of a kiss
of the kissing gate it's it's at a scale
but
i don't have the ability on this pdf to
scale from this right now
um to advise councillor stanley
precisely about
the disabled um where the disabled
access would be possible
um but what i would suggest is it would
be appropriate to put an informative on
because what we're going to get if this
is if this is approved this reserve
matters is approved
is more detail coming through in
relation to that condition on the
outline
so we can certainly make it clear to the
developer that what we expect
in relation to the discharge of
condition is the ability for
um buggies perhaps or for them to look
at that issue
and propose a design that's that's going
to work um
in relation to this same issue though um
councillor eves i think it was that
mentioned that this is going to serve
a moan path um and that is right
um this is towards the western side
of the western um bound of
the southern boundary um so the majority
of the
um built um sort of urban
part of rayleigh is to the east so
potentially most people are coming up
and would use the fort paths
um and access the open space
maybe from from a different point
crossing over the road
it could be that some people do and i
think if members
again wanted um sections of this to be
hard surfaced i don't think there's any
um
reason why again we couldn't put an
informative on
so that um as part of the discharge of
condition
we maybe get a different surface
treatment here this is
one way in um but there are if i just
zoom out
just to give you the overall perspective
there is a going to be a foot way along
the spine road here
but yes this is this moan path is the
only
sort of path through this part of the
public open space proposed at the
southern extent
because the actual bound path starts at
this point here
can you see my cursor here so this beige
path weaves then to the north
and then you've got two arms of that
bound gravel path
going over to the east
in relation to the dog bins and just
make it clear that we've got one dog
waist been proposed in this location
here
so this point in the y of the paths
um then there's one proposed
just outside the redlined area here but
the applicant has made clear
that they do propose one that's just
slightly within the residential envelope
here
there's another one proposed at this
point here but
in relation to cancer studies i think
specific point about the dog waste bins
being very close to the um
ponds where people might i suppose sit
and linger there is a bench proposed
here
we could again add that as an
informative um there's no reason why
the dog waste bins i don't think have to
specifically be in those locations
if we want an informative to suggest
that maybe they're closer to where
the ponds are people may linger and sit
for longer
there's also one proposed right to the
south again
right next to this kissing gate um
the dog waste bins will be managed by a
management company
and so it won't fall to the local
authority um it will be the management
company
and i do anticipate then that these bins
will be emptied on a regular basis
um any residents living on that site and
noticing a problem
will have a ready phone number to call
if the if there are problems um and
that's the service they're going to be
contributing to
so in number there are four proposed
um if members don't think that's
sufficient potentially we could
put an informative on um there is a
condition
proposed on the application to deliver
that
so if members felt strongly that more
were needed maybe we could alter that
condition
but i think there is some hopefully
quite strong guarantee that these will
be emptied regularly
um the other question i think
councillor steptoe had was regard to
railings around the attenuation
ponds none are proposed as
part of this specific reserve matters
application that doesn't prohibit
the developer putting in proposed
details of any um fencing or
sort of boundary treatment to these
attenuation areas as part of the
discharge of condition
relating to the landscaping um
in relation to the area to the north so
um
we've already as a council agreed
reserve matters in relation to this area
to the north
and the details of um the condition
and we haven't specifically required any
um fencing of this attenuation
pond one so this larger one um
clearly there is let me just go back to
the planets for approval tonight
the brook runs through the site and it's
certainly not proposed to fence that in
any way
what's proposed in relation to the brook
um
which obviously carries water at certain
times deeper than
other times of the year and heavy
rainfall events um
there is existing sort of um planting
around the margins of the brook which
would
be untouched and then it would be
supplemented as you get further away
with new planting
um so it sort of acts as a natural
buffer for people to
you know steer clear of that area these
attenuation basins will be designed to
hold
some water um and then at times of heavy
rainfall events will
fill to a higher level but the actual
profile of these
um has wide margin around the edge
um if i can zoom in then how how much i
can
um let me just i think i don't know if
you can see this on the screen this
one's probably
most obvious if you can see my cursor
here so there's a
a bound gravel footpath that is the
designated
footwear which will appear very obvious
to pedestrians and then alongside that
there is a three meter wide sort of um
access um around um it should be moan
grass but
it provides another sort of access
around there that's
that's a really um low incline
if if at all visible as an incline at
all um and then it very gradually
um sort of steps down will carry some
water
at the moment there is no um proposed
fencing
um as shown on the reserve matters
application to these attenuation ponds
and there wasn't in relation to the the
ponds in the area to the north
um and also
there is no specific details of any life
um sort of boy equipment
um at the moment um proposed
and i think that answers all the
questions whether there's any further
questions i'm happy to
i'll stop sharing see
okay thank you i can't counsel a hawkway
thank you chairman um on the basis of
what katie's
just said um i'd like to suggest
an informative in relation to the
um kissing gate and the uh the path
uh from the kissing gate that we would
look to
have a hard surface area
from the southern boundary from the
kissing gate for approximately 100
meters
um to try to prevent
the potential for the area to become
bogged down
in mud in the winter winter seasons
um and i'd also suggest an informative
to
add an additional
dog waste bin in in the vicinity of the
proposed bench
near the uh one of the um attenuation
basins
thank you uh cancer stanley do you wish
to
come back uh thank you chairman yes
um i would agree uh uh second that with
uh councillor hookway um to to have
these
uh looked into and uh to see what we can
do in
in ways of making that a cinder and not
just
cut grass as we know from the entrance
to swain park is
it just became muddy as as just a
quagmire basically
and it wasn't drained out so i would ask
if
if we could find out if if the if it
will be
higher than the land uh surrounding
or or whether there is a some sort of uh
dispersal of of water in that area
because
because that is quite a low area as you
very well know it does flood
on that part between the swallows
and the petrol station and we've had
flooding all the way up to
um uh come to zombs so
yes that is quite low and and i would
like that some sort of uh informative as
to what's going on what we can do with
that thank you
obviously there's a variety of
engineering solutions
so so members um there is a
recommendation
for approval which i i'll move this four
points
one to four plus the informatives
around the detail of the the access gate
which was described as the kissing gate
an additional dog bin
and then the making firm of the uh
of what what is currently described as
the moan
route so that the winter period the the
muddying up of the
the clay that we know we've got in this
area is dealt with
um would someone like to second that
that one
i'll second that thank you very much
right
members um i think we can go to the vote
now i can just confirm that everyone has
heard all of the discussion and evidence
and is in a now in a different
informed position to make a vote
no one's got an equipment breakdown that
needs
to vote by another method no that's good
okay um can i ask
you to raise your hand if you require a
recorded vote
no there isn't one right we'll do the
voting by the
click of hands so those members
in favor of the approval
as listed plus the informatives
please raise a hand now
[Music]
um
thank you if you drop the hands
um i think we
got 11. that was everyone wasn't it um
yeah yeah that was that's unanimous
so no need to vote to take a vote
against right thank you
very much on that one that item is
approved
um item nine
site of bournewood hall boomwood
hall lane hockley
thank you chair um this application is
the site of the former boardwood hall as
we just mentioned
um the prison that was
correct one small error on the
description you'll see that
i just asked you to start again
you broke up there significantly yeah
ah my apologies um on the
before we start the condition the
existing condition on page 9.1
under from condition 5 stating
the line reads the first floor windows
to house types
it should be the first floor side
windows
to house types and that will become
clear as we as we proceed
but to root to recover that
the application is site the form of
board hall which you'll see there on the
location plan
that's got a planning permission being
redeveloped for
72 houses now that permission was
subject to
a standard condition that we use
condition number five on that permission
that's set out in the report which
required the first floor side windows to
a number of the designs to be obscure
glazed and fixed shut
below a height of 1.7 meters above
uh first floor finish floor level inside
the building basically
to be at or below high height obscure
light
to maintain privacy between occupiers
the site is an advanced stage of
construction and if we can jump to
double o two
please following inquire is made by the
council's enforcement officers in
relation to complaints made by existing
residents members will recall there is a
group
of housing that i think was former
formerly associated with the staff of
the the uh
prison uh facility and
it became clear that the applicant had
uh departed from this condition there
was a number of windows installed the
the site is an advanced stage of
construction i'm not sure that all
houses are currently up to roof
level um but enough of them to be able
to be surveyed in the process of this
application
but it became clear that not all the
windows were fixed shut
as we required and it may well be that
some of them hadn't got to get glazing
in
so um the applicant uh
has now made this application to vary
condition five
on the basis that he felt that a blanket
approach
um was probably not necessary
and you'll see it's difficult to explain
but there's a number of
of windows that the applicant is saying
um
r-o-k and this gives you a spread
of uh the green walling that's been
indicated here
is gables with only obscure glazed
windows
and then the pink is gable with some
clear and first floor
windows so there's an overlooking issue
that
needs to be addressed which the
applicant now recognizes
now to compound matters when you seek
to single issue a condition and
address that we are obliged as local
planning authority to actually
re review and reissue the revised
decision notice it becomes complicated
because
the number of conditions that were
required to start with
fall away and that leaves those that are
just necessary
still now or for the con continuity of
the
the development so
although we're talking about a single
issue
officers have to present you with the
revised decision notices which is hence
the number of conditions in the
recommendation
that reflect the discharge of the
conditions on the journey of
the development hopefully that's clear
if we can jump to plan three please
the uh applicants have proposed a
condition
that in respect of the obscure glazing
of upper floors uh
on the windows that officers cannot
accept now
that's saying that the applicant has has
presented an alternative condition
five that was um but we can't accept
that
uh as as presented officers have looked
at every
plot under construction and found that a
variation between what was originally
proposed
or recommended as condition five and the
applicant's alternative
um could be you'll see that
some windows to specify plots must be an
officer's view
this is condition what is now condition
three
as a result of the sort of casualty of
uh having to re-jig the decision notice
so condition five would become condition
three
um you'll see that some of those plots
must in officers views still be obscure
glazed and fixed shut below 1.7 metres
uh finished four rivals as the condition
required
but others may have a restrictive hinge
if we can see plan
4 that the applicant has
has provided a design of a hinge that
can be
introduced to the existing windows that
give a restriction of 13 degrees that's
plan double 04 if you're hunting for
that
katie um to just see members it's an
exploded view it will fill the screen
but it will
it will show you there you go it will
show that there's a restrictor on that
design
that just allows it to be a jar
limiting uh views outside that open
window
so office design on specified plots
which is set out in condition
3 that this
this design can be adopted and then the
balance
of the windows can be
can be clear so the recommendation
chairman is therefore the
the application be approved subject to
this new consent
being written into the legal agreement
on the previous consent
and to the new conditions that are set
out in the report
thank you if we could just
lose the screen share please
all right thank you uh
councillor sparing would you like to
speak on this one
you're just on mute at the moment
fully appreciate the developers have
have only concentrated on
the windows but in the in their page
pages of of other issues
on page 9.4
they talk about construction traffic
control and delivery of construction
materials and plan which i find rather
ironic because the biggest problem
they're addressing it now because they
want something done for their windows
but the simple reality is this is a
major problem
that they failed to address since 2017
there is a continual problem and i would
like to think
that something could be done to draw
this to a developer's attention
because nobody else seems to want to
take on this issue and
it we've already had residents losing
fences down there
it's not acceptable what they are
proposing and this is just another area
where they've got things wrong thank you
chairman thank you
uh councillor uh stanley please
uh chairman could i ask mike strange
says
is the window to open with its hinge
at the top or is it opening
with the hinge on the left or the right
hand side
the reason that i asked this is that the
field of view
if it is hinged either left or right
is still wide you can still view across
whereas if the hinge is at the top the
view
would not be quite so you'd have to get
on your hands and knees to open the
window to get the view so
it is if it's just for is is the
idea of the window for ventilation which
i imagine it would be
um so there is is what what is the
makeup of the window frame and how it's
uh
held of the window okay thank you
counselor eves thank you chair
uh by nature of my business i'm very
aware of these kind of uh defender
limiter uh hinges they are very easy to
swap out
um what is to prevent a future occupier
from just swapping them out so as they
fully open
thank you nothing is on that but it
wouldn't comply with planning
consent uh councillor hookway
thank you chairman can i ask mr
strengths as to
whether the developer was
fully aware of condition five when uh
construction started or
so have they have they um ignored it or
have they um
have they uh um sort of like were
unaware of it during the course of their
construction it seems
that uh you know when we put these
conditions we are expecting them to
fulfill them um so what was their
reasoning for
um for not not complying with it i know
they're looking to alter it now
i just wondered if uh if if uh mrs trax
has got
any uh additional information in
relation to that thank you
when we do sum up the questions i'll
only ask mr strength do i
answer that one if he has had an answer
from the developer i wouldn't ask him to
speculate on that one
because i don't think that would be fair
councillor gooding
i i share councillor eve's concerns
regarding the restrictor
because i've obviously experienced in
those myself
so um i know that they are easily
removed
and i would really share my concerns
about that
it's not going to work not on the long
term
thank you um would you like to
gather those questions together mr
strengths please
thank you chairman um as you say i could
only speculate
a lot um and i'll leave it there on on
the awareness of the developer um i
don't know if katie can
uh show us double o4 which i think is
the
is the hinge detail my understanding
is that it would be on the bottom um
we're looking here at an aerial view
uh from above through the the sort of
light
bulb lines are the uh insulation
and the uh cross-hatched
to the top is the section through the
wall and then the
uh uh horiz 45 degree
lines are the inner wall so you'll see
that the window is recessed
into into the walling above the
insulation as it were on a sill
and i would i stand to be corrected by
anybody
more familiar with the construction but
i would say that's a bottom hinge
fixed in the in the window so it would
open
as you see from the the sort of pink
shading
to an acute angle that's the point it
will give some
limited view rather than being able to
open
the full window and i'll take your point
chairman that if that was removed
then we would have the ability to
enforce this is actually what's brought
the application forward the public have
complained
the uh enforcement team have
investigated
and the applicant has as is his right
brought forward an alternative proposal
um for us to consider so the enforcement
has worked
thank you chair thank you
um just
just wait for the share screen to go
the officer there mentioned uh about the
window there i
wasn't clear from the focus of the
picture the drawing there
does the window open inwards or outwards
that was that was that was a outwards
opening on the on the diagram we saw
i thought the officer was saying that
was inwards
just want to say inwards or outwards mr
strengths
outwards chair right thank you
councillor belton
thank you my experience with the
hinge restrictions is that they can be
um easily undone essentially
you with a with a very quick flip of a
switch you can undo it and i think that
might be because of
for health and safety or virus situation
but ultimately it always
almost deems the hinge pointless so i
just would ask
is it is it fixing situ so that it
cannot be adjusted
um or is it one that can easily be
adjusted with a with a flick
in which case is it sufficient thank you
members we've heard uh a number of
different points
counselor stanley do you want to come
back and suggest a way forward
yes please if you don't mind um
the from what i understand then
is the hinge is at the bottom
so that you can look out from from the
top which is
no no am i wrong so the hinge is on the
side
the window opens but only a short a
small amount
to 13 degrees
and opens outwards yes right so
what what i'm proposing then is uh
exactly the opposite to open
inwards that that
that would a window opening inwards
rather than outwards
i i i believe that would be a
fundamental
difference in the planning application
and so it wouldn't be appropriate for us
to
change something from opening out to
opening in i don't i don't
think that would be appropriate well
they are changing
they are changing the they are going
against what we've asked them to and
they're changing the window completely
yeah so they've applied to open the
window outwards
in some cases can we make a condition
then that the window should open
inwards that that that is
diametrically opposite to what is
applied for so i
i believe an application would
it a fresh application would need to
come in on on that case
would you like to just confirm my
viewpoint on that
mr strengths
i can chairman yes it's a specific
detail if members are unhappy with this
arrangement
then they would be looking to find the
proposal unacceptable
it would need a substitution of design
to my understanding yeah
yeah right okay
cancer fd you have indicated now
thank you chairman uh could the uh
window not open outwards but from the
top so the
sorry opens outwards so
the only gap will be at the bottom and
you still get air vent in and you
wouldn't have no side view
and all you guys used to do it open in
lots of ways but the application before
us this evening
is that way is to open sideways
you know bottom line is if you don't
feel in the
locations indicated that it is
acceptable
then you you won't agree with this
application
okay thank you chairman so um
you know having heard the conversation
uh the discussion
is there a member that wants to take
this forward in any other direction
before i take an action as the chair
councillor hawkway
you chairman um i'd like to put
forward a um proposal for refusal
okay could you state your reasons for
refusal please
um because i feel that um
the solution that's being offered by the
uh
the developers um does not meet
with uh our council's um
uh policy and requirements and
the possibility that it could be under
easily undermined
um uh with uh
the uh the the limitation of the the
hinging
thank you can i ask if there is any
member who wishes to second counsel the
whole question i'll second that
chairman please thank you seconded by
cancer stanley
okay members we have an
a motion for refusal put forward
by councillor hogway about the
non-compliance with the council's
requirement and the
lack of robustness um an
integrity of the proposed solution
um can i just confirm that all members
have heard the discussion
you're in a properly informed position
to
make a decision on on this one and
everyone's got their it working and not
going to be
uh restricted in in letting us know
what's going on
he's looking around the screen that's
all good
um i'll first of all ask if any member
wishes to have a recorded vote please
raise your
hand icon if necessary
no one has right
can i ask you to raise your hand if you
are in favor of the motion to
refuse this
i'm counting 11 and if 11 is the case
that makes that
unanimous thank you can drop your hands
that item is refused
um there are no item there is no item
10 so at 2047
i'll say thank you everybody for your
support
um as chairman of this uh
this committee and um it is for this new
municipal year where i say thank you
and good night good night chairman thank
you